know guys inflation's a real thing here
right it is you're going on dates right
attractive women guys take on dates
ever is it acceptable for a guy to say
hey let's split the bill
not happening not happening okay check
gentlemen now you understand okay
um
what about saying hey look uh
i know we're at a nice restaurant but
just please don't order the steak or
lobster let's just kind of keep it to a
salad no no not happening how about if
you invite me on a date yeah you're
gonna pay for it yeah i'm sorry yeah
we're taking the time to do our hair
again yeah okay
clothes nice shoes yeah expensive purses
like
no right and whatevs if he says listen
order whatever you want let's just not
you know drink because drinks are way
too expensive no if you invite me on a
date you're going to pay for it
so the way i see is we got two like you
wouldn't take a mercedes-benz to a
drive-through we got two mercedes-benz
next to us you know what i mean you
gotta you gotta go
you gotta give them that for example if
i'm gonna take my girlfriend out for her
birthday i would never tell her that so
if if i can afford to do that and this
[ __ ] tries to come and tell me
like no you're like oh you're going to
order the most expensive thing sorry
then you can't afford to have me next to
you i actually had a date it happened
like this
please explain
and it was actually like a big reality
star and
i'll just reveal that and he was a blue
check guys
i can't trust those [ __ ] he
like
it was kind of a similar situation he
asked me on a date
and like he went to the most expensive
right like he asked me on a date and
picked the most expensive restaurant he
picked all the foods because sometimes i
like that i'm like oh let the guy pick
because i have to do like a little
shared thing pick up family stuff yeah
family that's fine like you get to try
everything so he picked out everything
and he's just like um this is gonna be
so expensive like i don't know what to
do and
me and then what do you do 10 years
older than me too
at the time i mean he still is but
at the time
at the time like i was under 25.
then he was like kept complaining about
how much it was going to cost and then
he said he lost his wallet and i had to
pay for it
what the blue channel is
he lost his wallet and he said he had
you and you paid for it yeah do you
remember how much the bill was it was
definitely over 300 and i was like 24.
like i'm not balling
for
out the credit card how did you feel i
felt like [ __ ] okay as you're signing
the bill and i was like 60. right now
he's never getting another date he's
never getting anything okay and then
last question did he venmo you 300 bucks
no he just ghosted you bro homie if
you're listening you're a [ __ ] loser
yeah
so forget your wallet complain that it's
expensive have the girl do that
and then not even be like
again if you lost your card i lost your
wallet okay hey the girl back what are
you doing yeah because you're just like
if you invite the girl out and then you
you order everything because here's what
happens you know the most important
thing a person can have their reputation
so now this guy's reputation is
tarnished all over tv and internet right
now
well i have a similar story oh go ahead
and it's just someone that everybody
here knows his name
also with blue check mark but check this
out so
he he invited me to go out to lunch and
i was like okay sure
he was close to me in brickell
and
i was like let's go we go to lunch great
great first lunch uh meeting
then he goes like two days later he goes
hey uh my guy friends are in town how
about you get a couple of hot a couple
of your girlfriends that are good
looking and bring them out with you and
i was like cool because whatever i'm
chill like that i get my girlfriends to
come with me he's like we're just coming
we're just going to go for drinks so we
all ate the girls
so when we get to um uh
we get to this uh balance in in brickell
they're there sitting at a table getting
ready to eat and i was like oh i thought
you said that you know you guys oh no we
decided to eat now and i said well we're
not eating because we already ate there
was one more girl that was coming but
she hadn't eaten
so
she got to the table she ordered
something we all ordered just one drink
perfect they pay for us great
then they wanted to go somewhere to
smoke some hookahs we go to the hookah
lounge
and
um i ordered a drink my two other
girlfriends ordered two beers and
my girlfriend ordered another drink so
that's four drinks right
when he orders the check we were only
there for like 45 minutes
he goes
um
he's like they're gonna pay for their
own drinks and i'm gonna pay for their
guy these guys drinks
my girls looked at me like like what the
heck you know because the check was like
probably like 60 bucks or something like
that for four drinks so we went to the
bathroom and i was like what the [ __ ]
and this guy is all over like russell
brunson's walls that he's made 30 40 50
million dollars with his funnels
long story short i come out and and i
ended up paying and then i go by the way
in front of all of them this is a
[ __ ] embarrassment don't invite me to
bring my hot girlfriends to entertain
you and your friends you missed our 20
million dollar funnel and you make us
pay for our drinks you can go [ __ ]
yourself
and they they literally they got up like
literally so embarrassed don't waste my
time like that you know what i mean oh
my god so anyways yeah i had a story
like that never again what do you think
that's like a bro flux do you think
that's what it was what do you call it
like a bro flex for them to go in there
and be like yo we're going to get these
hot chicks over here and we're just
going to be like yo you take the no i
don't think that's what's going on but
what's the guy in mind
not a power move like a dude like a
douche move yeah
the next day he went on facebook said
what happened
right but his story is that we ate all
their dinners we got wasted on drinks
that that's not my personality number
one so completely lied and all of a
sudden you have a whole bunch of people
just bashing me the audacity of these
miami girls and i'm like oh my god this
isn't even how it happened
two months later he sends me a text
message that he wanted to see me again
if i could give him a chance i'm like
no well here's my two cents on this and
i've been very vocal about this if
i i look at three different things
eating by myself eating with my guy
friends eating with girls
if it's by myself dude i'm a minimalist
basic sandwich rap done i'm in i'm out i
don't give a [ __ ] like i'm not a foodie
at all done if i'm eating with my boys
and i've learned from experience we used
to do these monthly gentlemen dinners
the boys we're going out for dinners all
right we're going out to you know
morton's steakhouse or you know
uh what's the sushi place uh uh with the
z zuma zumi okay zoom oh motion most
emotions kidding me cat's in the emotion
uh zuma like we go to these fancy
dinners chop up a thousand dollar bill
between eight guys all right we're
spending 100 i'm like guys i'm done
i'm like why am i going to fancy dinner
with you [ __ ] losers like you know
like you're my boys like it's chicken
wings or nothing homie right okay maybe
not mcdonald's
if it's with the boys we're just doing
beers and chicken wings i don't have no
one to impress here by myself minimalist
with the boys basic if i'm taking a girl
out
i know nice restaurant dinner drinks a
couple hundred bucks no problem well
worth the investment if i'm into the
girl that's a decision that i've made
like budgeted for
yeah okay i'm not balling out with my
boys i don't care about you bro eat the
hamburger shut your face
eat with a girl whatever you want
whatever you want to drink and that's
what and that works out well for me what
are your thoughts on that i love it i
think that's great you know i mean if
that's if that's your rule that's great
for me
um when i go out um with a guy yeah i
like nice restaurants when i go out with
my girls if we want to go to nice
restaurants we go we pay for our bill uh
when it's just me i like to eat you know
just be at home meal prep and have my
own sweet potatoes and white rice and
some chicken and i ball out of them all
the time
you bought food by yourself yeah
sometimes i'll take myself
a
couple
to
capitol
is not like that to me hey you know what
true you're saving don't love yourself
who else is going to love you okay fair
enough but i'm like i'm not going to be
like adam you've killed it this week
just go out pull up the seat at the
steak house by yourself spend 300 bucks
no dude okay i don't know you're going
to subway
i like to go to north italia i go there
a couple times a week have a nice salad
my check will be like 35 40 bucks do you
do you beautiful women eat by yourself
at restaurants you do that all the time
you do that yeah do you do i even go to
the movies by myself
by yourself
don't do that i'm going to be myself
staying home
i'm like what do you do i'm pretty
minimalistic if it's by myself yeah like
i could eat like a piece of bread that's
in in the fridge
i heard a dirty rumor about you that you
just have random hamburgers that you
just warm up in the microwave and your
girl had to cut them off i've had to
grow out of that
melissa would love this because my uh my
partner um she
will not she is super health nut we are
doing tumeric shots in the morning you
know like so what you see on there is uh
not to you know destroy the illusion for
all y'all at home but we see on there
it's like very much fabricated
um um but it's you know it's it's very
relatable to like i guess the there's so
many people like you said with inflation
like there's so many people struggling
to make it ends me and you know what
sucks about not having money you can't
afford to be healthy hmm that's true
very well said the more money you wake
the make the more
yeah
that's why i'm driven to work that's
what i'm driven to provide because i i
know that this this world is cut throat
and and you need you need money like to
be able to provide and also be able to
take care of yourself um you know
medical bills or whatever especially
eating well like sprouts and whole foods
yeah that's what they say whole foods is
whole paycheck
they make healthy food so expensive yeah
it's just
expensive like if you want to be healthy
and want to live longer last question on
this topic we'll move on so
uh
women uh ladies uh is there
is the best date a nice
dinner date nope i think it's the worst
you think that's the worst yeah why i
think i want something that's
adventurous something like axe throwing
or bowling or a little throwing or let's
go like you know
um
absolutely so you like an activity day
time or night time uh i actually like
nighttime okay i guess you do
[Laughter]
i mean i like a nice dinner date but i'm
half deaf so it's like hard and i like
dinner date like not a lot of noise
because i i can't hear the gun because
what one of your ears i'm deaf in my
right ear but i also one of the best
dates have ever gone on until this day i
remember it and the guy just never
really worked out as he took me like he
had his pilot's license and he took me
on a flight and had a picnic so i think
like well thought out dates like that
like he's like hey i got but like
initiative is so hot like hey we're
gonna meet me here at this time we're
gonna do this i'm like yes sir
[Laughter]
how about you natalia um i like
activities but i do enjoy dinner dates i
feel like
like for me i find it attractive to
watch a man like order the dinner
eat pay for it all of those things make
me more attractive to the guy now after
we can go do some like activities you
know we started off with like a meal or
something but
um
i like dinner dates i think it's a nice
way to like have a conversation i'm not
deaf but i do have bad hearing so i'm
the same like too much going on i can't
if a guy just asked like hey can meet up
for drinks i say no
that's not working no
no because i can't hear you i mean
honestly i like to get to know you but
you can go to a nice restaurant at the
bar and like have a few drinks maybe
order an appetizer like that could be
like maybe like
randomly anytime a guy has asked me just
for drinks it's just been solidly drinks
it's like a bar that's like loud and
um so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire saucecast click right
here
[Music]